foreign
[Music]
[Music]
lies and the sussexes as the monarchy
Embraces itself for more mudslinging on
Netflix Harry and Megan's latest bibs
are lay bare
Britain is rocked by the biggest wave of
winter strikes in decades in rail chaos
threatens direct Christmas for Millions
I'll talk to the government Minister who
so far failed to get a grip
plus the infamous con man behind fire
Festival was jailed for one of the
biggest frauds in music history now he's
back with a new Rouge should he be
allowed to he joins me live
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening for London
welcome to Piers Morgan on send some
reviews for Harry and Megan's big budget
Netflix series have so far been less
than kind unimaginative and frustrating
said Hollywood's Bible variety magazine
so sickening I almost brought up my
breakfast said the woke Bible the
guardian or the intimacy of Instagrams
near the normally timid New York Times a
nauseating self-serving snooze Fest said
another pundit well that was me actually
now I guess this Deluge of derision
Netflix today released a new trailer for
the second half of this compelling
series which comes out on Thursday
viewer discretion is advised this clip
contains weapons-grade hypocrisy
I wonder what would have happened to us
had we not gone out when we did our
security was being pulled everyone in
the world knew where we were I said we
need to get out of here
on the freedom flight
to see this institutional gas lighting I
wasn't being thrown to the Wolves I was
being fed to the Wolves they were
actively recruiting people to
disseminate disinformation they're happy
to lie to protect my brother they were
never willing to tell the truth to
protect us Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle the Rogue Royals
they just wanted to be free
they wanted to be free to love and be
happy
I applauded that
in order for us to be able to move to
the next chapter you've got to finish
the first chapter it gave us a chance to
create that home that we had always
wanted
[Music]
I've always felt as though this was a
fight Worth Fighting For
lighting says Harry do you think even
knows what that means
they were happy to lie to protect my
brother who the Royals
me media who is it the irony is
earth-shattering isn't it Harry and
Megan the Duke and Duchess of
gaslighting themselves the entire show
is a cynical attempt to manipulate
viewers into questioning their own
Recollections of reality
and if we learned anything at all from
the first three hours of this hundred
million dollar wine-a-thon it's surely
that this dismal Duo wouldn't know the
truth if it's smack them around their
smug chops let's look at their Truth
versus the actual truth
Mega moans at Royal advisors forced her
to uninvite her dear niece Ashley from
the wedding the only member of her
family that she seemed to be still
talking to
how do we explain that this half-sister
isn't invited to the wedding but that
the half-sister's daughter is
and so
with Ashley the guidance of the time was
to not have her come to our wedding
yeah that was a lie
impeccably placed Royal sources told the
Sunday Times no such guidance was ever
given
and that was supposed to be the show's
big example of how Megan really cares
very deeply about her family so deeply
that only one member of that family was
at the wedding her mother not even her
favorite little niece Ashley
Megan also sees she got no advice on
Royal protocol forcing her to learn how
to be a princess all on her own
joining this family I knew that there
was a protocol for how things were done
there is no class in some person who
goes sit like this cross your legs like
this use this Fork don't do this curtsy
then wear this kind of hat it doesn't
happen
another lie and by the way Megan if you
don't like me calling you a liar just
sue me and we'll go through all this in
court
there's suddenly times discovered she
was actually handed a 30-point dossier
studiously research brimming with
information and contacts Megan Ledger
simpers that she never wore bright
colors to show respect because she's all
about respect
so I was like well what's a color that
they'll probably never wear
camel beige white so I wore a lot of
muted tones but it also was
so I could just blend in
like I'm not trying to stand out here
no the last thing Mega mark would ever
want to do is stand out but it's all one
other life photos taken by the evil
bigoted British press show her wearing
pretty much every color in the rainbow
the show opens with a claim that the
royal family declined to comment on the
series that's another lie the palace
says it received one email from an
unknown company an attempts to verify it
was flatly ignored even the story of
their romance and engagement turns out
to be in a series of Whoppers they told
the BBC in 2017 they were set up by a
mutual friend on a blind date they told
Netflix they met on Instagram and what
about Harry's Modest Proposal in their
humble cottage kitchen
uh it happened a few weeks ago earlier
this month here at our Cottage
um it's a standard typical night for us
cozy night it was what we're doing just
roasting chicken and having him
and it was just
an amazing surprise it was so sweet an
amazing surprise it was so sweet well
according to Netflix which is their show
it was actually a candle Extravaganza in
their Walled Garden
and Megan was so amazingly surprised she
managed to figure out what was happening
until her friend about it before Harry
even popped the question
a small little detail but rather like
their claim or Megan's claim that they'd
been secretly married by the Archbishop
of Canterbury in their Garden before
three days before the big televised
wedding which also turned out not just
to be untrue but had it been true would
have led to the Archbishop Academy being
incarcerated in prison
as with all things Megan and Harry it
would seem the truth just doesn't really
exist in their world it's their truth
their version of it
Megan also lambasted the entire BBC
engagement if he was rehearsed and an
orchestrated reality show because that's
the last thing she'd be engaging in
isn't it an orchestrated reality show
like the Netflix series
Michelle Hussein from the BBC who
carried out the interview said actually
no it was just an interview even the
BBC's long-serving Royal correspondent
Nicholas witchell normally bent double
to avoid upsetting absolutely anybody in
Royal circles can't take it anymore
consider one of the things that Megan
said no matter what I did they were
still going to find a way to destroy me
well the first point who is the they
that she's referring to I think it is
the palace but most particularly it is
to the Press but the idea that anyone
was out to destroy her frankly I think
is absurd and simply does not stand up
to a proper and reasonable scrutiny well
that's Nicholas witchell's way of saying
you're lying and he's right
they lie all the time nothing they ever
say seems to stand up to reasonable
scrutiny and I say that as somebody who
lost his last job presenting Good
Morning Britain because I wouldn't
apologize for saying I didn't believe
Meghan Markle think about that
well just like they've failed to ever
provide a shred of evidence for their
claims of racism in the palace or
Megan's claims over mental health
problems she said that they were not
just ignored by the palace but she was
told she wasn't allowed to get any help
for Suicidal Thoughts by somebody at the
palace who was that person
they shouldn't be working at the palace
we've never had a name like we've never
had any names about the racism
today's new trailer makes clear that the
gloves are off in the next three
episodes of the show and remember this
is just a warm-up then there's Harry's
book coming in early January
hundreds of pages of more allegations
about his family
there will be mud slinging incendiary
claims Bombshells and I fear a lot more
lies and on behalf of the British people
the monarchy they're trashing I intend
to call out every single lie that they
utter in their attempt to not just
destroy the royal family but to
potentially bring down the British
Monarchy well joining me now is the
organizer of battle lives matter
protests Iman 8 former head of Royal
protection dye Davis and talk to me
presenter Sharon Osborne Over in Los
Angeles Sharon great to have you on the
program
um I don't know about you I got about
halfway through the first installment of
this wine-a-thon last Thursday and felt
genuinely nauseous I mean I could feel
vomit Rising inside me but also a sense
of tedium like we'd heard all this
before with Oprah nothing really seemed
that new it was just a new gloss but on
all this stuff but the main purpose of
it just seemed to be to attack the royal
family to attack the institution of the
a monarchy to attack Britain as a racist
country what do you make of all this
very distinct
I was totally bored by The Whining The
Whining the whining and you know the
curtsy the things she said about
Medieval Times her lunch with the queen
was like Medieval Times which as you
know is a Disney type
um entertainment place for kids and it's
just so horribly disrespectful and just
a wine vest I mean what is the book
going to be the same thing whining
whining is there going to be no positive
points and that whole thing of him
um
filming himself on the freedom flight
they must have had that deal with
Netflix done months before they ever
left so the whole thing was a setup a
setup a setup why unless you had a deal
why would you have done that filming of
yourself on the plane and all of that so
what kind of Freedom video diary what
yeah and what kind of freedom is it if
all you're doing is living in your
California mansion with unbelievable
privilege and wealth and you're signing
all these deals with companies who want
their pound of Flesh and that pound of
flesh is exclusively trashing your
family
I mean this is all they do from the
Oprah interview onwards is trash their
family
trash but there's nothing about
themselves you know and this is a great
time for them to keep talking about
their charity but no it's about them
being these poor little children who are
so much in love and how abused they've
been their race the way they act
everything has been you know abused by
the public by the Press by the royal
family well do you know what you've got
a great life you've got a beautiful
family you're so much in love move on
get a life move on
and they just can't seem to because
they're living is by telling their truth
on the royal family that's how they make
their living yeah um their truth is yeah
I know I agree um Dave is on the
question of their security specifically
because you were obviously responsible
for a lot of Royal security for many
years Harry claims that they were sort
of had their security all taken away is
that even remotely likely to have been
true
well no the answer is absolutely not the
uh Protection Team followed them to
Canada it was when they moved from
Canada to the United States somebody far
higher than I in my present role or my
old role decided along with a committee
that decides this called ravac they
decided that it was no longer
sustainable for British police officers
to continue and I totally and utterly
agreed and can I say the last time you
and I spoke we were talking about the
Liza Uncle
um his Uncle Andrew put across and here
we are again as an investigator as you
rightly have said and many others there
are so much inconsistencies in this
there are so many half truths and my
concern is as I said having had some
information from Texas as to the number
of individuals there who have believed
this Hook Line and Sinker yeah and if
you know your history of attacks on the
Royal family as I do then you would
start to realize this is potentially
very serious indeed not only for the
royal family but for a fixated person on
either side to get in touch and cause as
it did with President Reagan as it did
with her majesty a queen last Christmas
a man with a crossbow
etc etc every year over a thousand
referrals are made to the fixated threat
Assessment Center most of them are
harmless but amongst them there is a
hardcore who could pose serious risk and
that's what I've been concerned about as
a consequence of this nonsense that's
been spewed out by these two and some of
their supporters yeah I completely agree
okay look Martin we've had some a lot of
you know animated debate about this and
I completely respect a lot of the stuff
that you've been saying vice versa uh my
issue with this is I I'm not sure what
the supposed end game is or how much
more of this was supposed to stomach I
mean this is another three hours of
trashing coming on Thursday then the
book then a series of interviews around
the book this is just a never-ending
stream of attacks on their own family
I appreciate that's how you feel but
ultimately what they're really doing is
highlighting the disgusting elephant in
the room that the majority of this
nation are more than happy to ignore and
that's what's happening right now and
they're trying to do it in a way that
allows them to look after their family
basically so if it means making money
once they do it what is that elephant in
the room
racism racism in terms of racial
Prejudice within institution and racism
in terms of this country being racist
but I said to you the other day when
things got a bit heated at this desk
that I felt that if you're going to make
incredibly serious charges of racism in
an institution like the British royal
family and the monarchy you've got to
provide some evidence they've now had a
year and a half or more since the Oprah
Winfrey interview in which they made all
these incendiary claims they've not
produced any evidence of any racism okay
so what I'm hoping is that these next
set of documentaries they will actually
provide us with some names so we can
kind of stop this what if it doesn't go
if it doesn't well what I'll do is I'll
provide you with my evidence is that all
right if you give me a minute I'll give
you some evidence as to why this that
specific institution is racist which I
can do so in terms of the evidence that
you are likely to find it is going to be
in the form of covert racism and I know
you don't like that word but it is a
fact so examples include in terms of the
institution the distribution of the
order of since Michael which is a badge
which ultimately depicts a white man
with wings trampling a black man we can
also delve into the fact that that
institution hung up pictures of a little
black slave boy on the Walls Within the
institution and everyone was so blinded
by their racial Prejudice that no one
saw fit to take it down when the black
president popped around for tea or we
can delve into the fact that the Queen
Elizabeth or rather the lake Queen made
sure that she did not have to adhere to
the equality's rules and legislation
which is arguably what a true racist
would do and we cannot take away the
facts
exactly in the true racist no I'm saying
it's arguably what a true racist would
do
she couldn't have been a less racist
person okay if she had tried okay ask
anyone in any of the commonwealth
countries about the queen none of them
ever felt the queen was a racist yes
when you say things like that you lose
me I'm like that's that's a ridiculous
thing to say okay so I'll explain it so
racism was the building blocks for the
transatlantic slave trade a trade that
was funded by the royal family and they
ultimately made their wealth off of
Blood Sweat and Tears off of enslavement
it was this country that actually led
the end of slavery which Everyone likes
hundreds of years ago by the way but you
also contributed to it and what you fail
to realize is that the legacy of
colonialism slavery and British
politeness a vital role in the
perpetuation of covert racism in other
words the present-day racism that I talk
about today which is in the form of
covert race so would you just so you've
described the late queen as a
effectively a true racist and you think
the country is racist okay so if anyone
that doesn't think that this country is
racist no no are we a racist country or
are we a country that actually is
remarkably tolerant has extraordinary
Multicultural Society but includes some
racist people which one is it so if you
don't don't think this is a racist
country you should probably speak to
Diane Abbott the black footballers who
have the content of racism on a daily
basis or we can delve into 85 000 people
who you're saying because a few people
can I just finished yeah yes or we can
delve into the 85 000 people who
reported racially motivated hate crimes
in 2021 and it's subsequently gone up to
a hundred thousand right or we can delve
into the 120 000 people have left their
jobs in the last five years due to
racism or we can delve into the quarter
of staff and 56 of students within
higher education that have to contend
with racism or if none of those are
accepted would you I'm happy for you my
platform
I have no I do not dispute for a moment
there are vile races in this country I
don't dispute for a moment if you troll
enough on social media you'll find them
but I do think they are the ugly little
Barnacles peering out from rocks I don't
believe that they are actually what this
country stands for I don't believe the
vast majority of people in Britain are
racist I don't think we're an
institutionally racist country and I
certainly don't think the queen had a
racist bone in her body which is why
she's such a beloved figure in the
Commonwealth so can I just add that
again I said it to you last time this
country has a very rudimentary
understanding of racism often referring
to overt racism as the defining Factor
foreign
racism is you end up with people like
Meghan Markle who say I was a victim of
racism but don't feel they have any
compulsion to have to say what actually
happened when it happened and who said
it and that is if that's covert racism
the problem with it is there's no hard
fact to support it but that's the issue
with okay so firstly I will preface my
statement by saying I agree with you it
should be known that's that's the fact
it should be known as she should make a
point of saying it I really do hope that
she does But ultimately like I said this
is about her highlighting a truth for
truth that many people are failing to
acknowledge and like I said
an odd framework Sharon look these are
pretty incendiary comments from Iman
here that we are a racist country that
the queen effectively was a true racist
covertly or otherwise I mean I find
those comments pretty offensive what do
you think
I think that as in every country in this
world there are a sects that are
anti-semitic racists there always will
be no matter what they always will be
because there's good and bad in every
race there's always a little group of
these nasty little evil people that
dislike someone because of color or
religion those are the two main dislikes
so yes there is a certain
um minority in England that are very
racist and a very anti-semitic okay and
I can say that being a Jew so the thing
is it's never going to end it hasn't
ended for thousands of years why should
it end now but you carry on you don't
get these people a platform
you'd want to talk about somebody with a
platform Kanye West he is he has
millions of followers that follow him
that adore him and will do what he wants
them to do you see I actually think I
actually think Meghan markle's country
is an overall racist no and I think
Meghan Markle Brandon is a racist
country and attacking the institution
the monarchy is racist it's something I
think actually I think she is she is
what I would call a race beta if she
doesn't produce hard evidence to support
these incendiary claims she becomes a
race beta exploiting racism and the
issue of racism to act as a kind of
protective shield around her and to make
herself extremely rich and famous as a
professional victim last word to die
Davis die just as somebody who has been
around the royal family for many many
years how do you feel about the way the
reputation of the royal family is being
so produced in this way
well I'm appalled frankly uh some people
see racism around the corner uh racism
is in Africa it's in India it's in every
continent and so to pick on the royal
family in this way is both insulting
it's also insulting most of the media
are very decent people I know a huge
amount of people for the last 50 odd
years in the media most like you and I
are decent people to vilify both the
Royals the media and the nation and
somehow imply we're all racist is
nonsensical in my opinion and I I just
despair that there are so many who will
take the word of proven liars and then
translate it into this issue about
racism and you were around the queen a
lot on this suggestion that she was some
covert racist herself what do you say to
that
unbelievable nonsense
thank you di appreciate you joining me
thank you Sharon uh over there in LA
hope to catch up with you soon thank you
Mom for joining me I appreciate it well
coming next uh trains nurses ambulance
workers postal workers just about
everybody seems to be going strike in
the run up to Christmas will the
government get a grip on the winter of
discontent I'll talk to the Royal
Minister Hugh Merriman next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back up to two Christmases
written by the covert pandemic this
year's festivities we're supposed to be
a hard-earned and belated celebration
for millions of long-suffering British
families that said Britain's facing his
biggest wave of winter strikes in
decades including train strikes set to
wreck Christmas travel joining me now
it's conservative MP of well Mr Hugh
Merriman Mr Berryman thank you for
joining please Morgan uncensored
um just as I was about to start talking
to you the uh breakdown in talks of the
nurses and the government has just been
announced which means there will be
nursing strikes this adds to the very
long list now of people who are going on
strike in the next two to three weeks
onto Christmas there's a general feeling
that this government has completely lost
control here what is going on and when
are you going to fix it
well I don't believe we've lost control
we've made a number of offers across the
sector many of which have been backed by
independent pay body recommendations
which we followed we've tabled those
offers we've then had discussions in
many departments including my own I had
more today to try and persuade the
unions of the merits of those offers but
Piers we have to balance it with the
cost if we gave every public sector
worker what they were looking for in
terms of inflation pay Awards it would
cost every household a thousand pounds
so we have a duty to balance the needs
of the workforce but also the needs of
every other household around the country
that will end up footing the bill for
these at a time when times are tight and
the private sector awards are much lower
than those that the public sector unions
tend to be looking for so we're trying
to find that balance we're trying to act
reasonably we're trying to follow advice
and we're trying to facilitate an end
but ultimately it takes the unions to
compromise as well I mean obviously the
problem you've got is the unions feel
embolden because they perceive the
government to be in a chronic likely
weak condition they've watched what's
happened in the last year in particular
three prime ministers four or five home
secretaries endless chancellors coming
and going the economy tank the pound
tanked you know there's trust lasting
less than the lettuce they put it all
together and they thought this is the
time to get together which they clearly
are doing and take you guys down and you
know what they might be successful the
The Fallout from all this might be so
bad that it is the Tipping Point for
this government and is the final blow
and leads to a labor government
well he is the prime minister made it
absolutely clear that his number one
priority is gripping inflation and
that's why we've we've taken the step to
ensure that we do not pay
um increases that go beyond inflation
and don't go to inflation and so that
was the prime minister's commitment when
he thought the leadership contest at the
beginning of summer is his commitment
now because inflation makes everyone
poorer and the poorest the poorer of
them all so that's the prime minister's
number one priority and that means that
pay restraint will have to be recognized
across the board so I believe that we've
got the resolve there we've also seen
what happens when government spends
money it doesn't have the markets
reactors they did and again that's
something that we're not willing to do
under this new government so I do feel
we're gripping it um that means we'd
have to take tough decisions and we have
to hold out in certain circumstances
rail being a good example of that within
my portfolio but that's something we're
determined to do so we want to act
reasonably talk try and facilitate an
end to this but our message is clear we
cannot have inflation and running
rampant paying Rises that go anywhere
near to inflation or above it will just
make the situation even worse and that's
our line what do you say to people who
say okay so you can't afford to give the
nurses pay rights is it the moment there
was a pandemic you began chucking
billions and billions of what appeared
to be any Tom Dick and Harry pitching up
who said they could make PPE or whatever
it was often ended up making unusable
PPE but but pocketing tens of millions
of pounds sometimes hundreds of millions
they've looked at that looked at the way
the government just handed out cash like
Father Christmas for two years but now
that the nurses who we all went and clap
for on Thursday nights the saving lives
in the pandemic and risking their own
now they want a proper pay rise they're
told there's no money left
well the nurses did a heroic job over
the pandemic and they continue to do so
because the NHS obviously has its
pressures but what you're talking about
with a 19.2 percent pay increase is an
extra 10 billion pounds onto the budget
of the NHS which then comes out of the
NHS so it'll actually make the situation
even more challenging in terms of what
happened during covid you know peers
that there is an inquiry that's been set
up that will look at absolutely
everything those overseeing the inquiry
will have full access to all of the
papers so um that's something to be
determined so I can't sort of Link the
two together but what I can say is that
19.2 is just a pay rise that we cannot
afford even the labor party have
admitted that they can't afford that
either we have offer talks um Steve
Barkley has made that quite clear so we
want to find a resolution but we just
need the nurses to recognize that 19.2
percent is something that no household
and the NHS can afford you see I would
agree with you I think that is an
unworkable resolution I don't think
anyone can make expecting to get more
than inflation from any sector frankly
and I would give the nurses pretty much
anything but there's got to be a reality
check but what about the state of the
NHS I mean one of the reasons they
they're contemplating this unprecedented
strike is because they all feel so
disillusioned they all feel overworked
underpaid they've lost Staffing numbers
in droves if you go to any busy hospital
now in the country on at the weekend in
particular it's complete chaos in there
you know my heart goes out to all these
people working in not just hospitals but
the care sector too after all they've
been through in the last two three years
you know so I don't think they should be
getting 19 but they should certainly be
getting due recognition for the
extraordinary efforts they've made and
the wider question for your government
is after all these years in government
why is the NHS in such a tattered state
well the NHS of course has had severe
challenges not just from the Aging
population and social care issues that
we all know about but also as you've
picked up yourself the pandemic and
we've got a backlog we're starting to
clear that backlog thanks to the work of
the NHS staff it is a big challenge
we're putting extra money in to try and
get more people out of hospital when
they don't need to be there because
that's not right for them or the
hospitals so back into social care where
they'd be better looked after and we've
also got a longer term plan now to
ensure that we've got the Staffing
modeling that we need over a period of
years that's something that Jeremy Hunt
when he was chair of the health select
committee was very keen on and he
announced that in the budget so I would
like nurses to to and indeed all those
that work across the NHS to take away
from from this that we recognize the
pressures that they faced in their job
we recognize what they do and they do a
fantastic job we want to help them to to
make the NHS more efficient and deliver
better but the challenge for us is that
if we pay out a 19.2 pay rise then we
can't do do
both in that sense so we're asking for
the a pay rise
a discussion that makes it a more
reasonable figure and then we can look
to see what can be done but I just want
to be absolutely clear we need to ensure
that the pay Rises do not breed
inflation because that just makes
everyone poorer one of the other
problems you have I would say in terms
of the perception is your recently
departed Health secretary throughout the
pandemic Matt Hancock has been raking it
into the tune of hundreds of thousands
of pounds eating kangaroo testicles in
an Australian jungle on relative
television doing another reality TV show
writing a book of fake Diaries which
were concocted after the event which
make him look great everybody else
looked useless and is now releasing
Tick-Tock videos here's a video he
released today
oh my God I can't believe it's two years
ago today that we did the first vaccine
in the world in Coventry and then I
cried on TV so embarrassing
well it was embarrassing mainly because
I was the one that was interviewing him
at the time when he burst into apparent
tears and there were no actual tears I
mean everything about Matt Hancock seems
to be fake and embarrassing but if
you're a nurse watching this health
secretary who then had to quit and
disgrace because he broke his own
lockdown rules if you watch him raking
it in literally he's heading towards
Millions now from if he's shameful
running of the pandemic and his shameful
departure from government how difficult
does that make your position as part of
a government now trying to persuade
nurses they shouldn't be entitled to a
few extra hundred pounds
well appears you can see my backdrop I'm
here in Parliament which is where I
always am because that's my job that's
what my constituents sent me here to
represent uh they did not send me to go
on to reality TV shows and I think the
government have made it quite clear from
the Prime Minister downward so that's
not where an MP should be spending their
time when they're elected by the public
to do a job that we should all be
privileged and proud to do and in my
view you can only do that by being in
Parliament and going through the
division lobbies and taking part in
debates so clearly my my style is
different to mats in that particular
sense he'll have to account for himself
as for tick tock um I promised my
youngest daughter that I've never never
be on it and I never have so I can't
account for that either we we all do
things differently well I would say is
the vast majority of MPS and ministers
work incredibly hard and will be found
here late on a Monday evening voting and
that's something that I just asked to be
sort of well I'm gonna win uh I'm gonna
win an outline okay I'm going to end
with a concession to you because we're
both Arsenal fans and in fact you've
berated me in the House of Commons we
are over Arsenal um but you've got
particularly exercise with me when I
demanded the head of Mikhail arteta on a
plate after he went through two
unsuccessful Seasons I believed he was
not entitled to a massive pay rise not
entitled to a New Deal you haranged me
on Twitter for this and Mr Merriman I am
I I'm big enough to admit that you were
right uh arteza has turned out to be a
an excellent manager on the top of the
league and although it sticks in my
gullet to do this I have to accept that
you were right and I was wrong
well that shows the great man they are I
wasn't going to raise it but uh I I
think it's nice that you have I think
he's doing an amazing job and hopefully
we'll both be smiling uh at the end of
the season I was hoping the season would
almost stop now but uh let's see if we
can gave more points on the board I
totally agree Mr Merriman thank you very
much for joining me
thanks Pierce
well come on thanks guys Southgate says
he's conflicted about his future should
he carry on his ignorance manager I'll
get reaction from my bank and give you
my verdicts
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to pierce organized I'm
joined by today's pack talk TV
contributors Esther cracker and Daily
Mirror Associates Kevin McGuire well
welcome back all right so it's the it's
the hope that kills every time
England for well for the 56th year since
we won it in 66 when I was one year old
uh we failed to win a major tournament
um but it's odd Kevin I'm not feeling
the normal Fury you know demands for the
manager to be sacked all the normal
stuff that goes on there seems to be a
different mood in the air and it's one
which is like you know what we've
actually got a pretty good team we've
got a pretty impressive manager we
nearly won the Euros last time we
narrowly lost to the world champions
this time and could have won it if Harry
Kane had scored the second penalty you
know these kids the young kids the
superstars of his team phone Bellingham
and Saka they're all very very young
yeah why would we get rid of Southgate
you wouldn't would you and you would
hope he would stay but you could see why
he will reflect he's taken England so
far since we are humiliated by Iceland
in 2016. yeah it might be Iceland uh at
the euros and he's got a world a world
cup um quarter he's got a World Cup
semic Euro final no I hope he stays he's
at his contract but what I like about
Southgate is the fact he might not and
he's thinking about yeah I agree yeah
and I think he has changed the culture
with the team
matters though yeah actually when I find
some of the virtually signaling a bit
over the top all the Unbound stuff I
could do with that but I do think that
they're a decent group of people led by
Harry Kane is a decent guy and I think
they try and do the right thing yeah
rather than go out of their way to do
the wrong thing yeah exactly and I I
think um he's been blessed so I think
he's been blessed with a fantastic
generation of players I don't see why he
would he would go and I didn't watch the
France and England match feeling
embarrassed by the way we played which
is important I think everyone says
I think we've got a very good chance of
winning the Euros in Germany because I
think our young players will be two
years older Bellingham is already world
class he's 19. yeah the second was
fantastic he's just gonna get better
yeah no no I think that you you look at
that team he can take it on so I hope he
stays but I do like the fact that he
hasn't just automatically said yeah I've
got a nice are you going to a Christmas
party
yeah are you yes are you so what are you
going to call it
it's well it's just a Christmas party
civil servants have been told to refer
to Christmas party as this Festive
Celebrations if as part of new woke
guidance on inclusion because people
from other Faith may not like the word
Christmas God spare me yeah look if you
want to call your party a festive
celebration I'd still come along but
they've been tonight they've been told
not to but I might I might think you've
got your tongue in your cheek when you
do that but then there are more diverse
groups who think it's respectful
it's a Christian country so I'm not
going to go to Dubai it is a Christian
country didn't you see the census
rooted in Christian Traditions I'm not
going to go to the Middle East and not
wish right
um where you get those vegan sausage
rolls they have more salt in them than
McDonald's cheeseburgers
um they brought in pronouns of Staff
name batches after feedback from
employees which include the usual she
her hers him him his they them that even
though they're singular people who call
themselves they never quite get that or
Neo pronouns this is a new one for me
which apparently conclude Z and Zia and
FEI and fear before you answer I just
want to clip my fingers for the old
the world
[Applause]
who is gonna walk around a Greg selling
ghastly vegan sausage rolls with a badge
saying zero and FEI Fair what does it
even mean and you can never choose a fun
one you can never say like guess what
does it mean my highness you're both
triggered again no I just let people be
if you're gonna choose your pronouns
choose a fun one mine would be your
highness yeah you could still get if I
were a badge if I wore a badge right
walking around the street just said
[ __ ] right well I mean you let you
go you go don't be so ridiculous right
if I wore one was easy what does it mean
I'd attempt to respect you if you went
yeah
I would defend you as many of my attacks
I've got a more natural effendency than
that with the word Z if the Greg Boss
class said you must wear these badges I
would I would push back but if the staff
want to wear them what's wrong
I don't want to go Greg's full stop
because it might slip me a vegan sausage
roll but I don't want to just be 4 of
this pronoun nonsense everywhere if you
want to wear one in your own home get on
with it what you're going to say look
there's a chicken sandwich I can't have
that now I've seen your shoes
on your badge but who is it hurting to
not have pronouns in there but just just
take a guess yes but this is if the
staff want them there's a reason they
want to respect other stuff they are the
customers they've been as Elon Musk
would put it they've been contracted
with the woke virus it's a very
afflicting thing I'm gonna bring in
chill pills for you too next I'm just
saying it's apparently absurd I don't
you know I'm going for a sausage roll
not to find out what Z Zero's real name
is it's not going to put you off really
because it's weird it is weird that
people
they're not people they're weirdos yeah
that's the problem all right thank you
Pat good to see you we're coming next on
like the fire Festival was advertised by
a-listers like jar rules with Ja Rule
Kendall Jenner and Bella Hadi ridiculous
selling for as much as 75 000 husband
telling me complete Fiasco and his
founder and organizer Billy McFarland
was jailed well he's out of jail and he
joins me next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS fire Festival promised Superstars
luxury and fine dining in a Caribbean
Paradise instead it became a fiasco that
left founder Billy McFarland sentenced
six years in jail owing 26 million
dollars to investors which remains
unpaid here's a reminder of what's been
called the biggest fraud in music
festival history immortalized in a hit
Netflix documentary
the actual experience exceeds all
expectations and is something that's
smart all these things that may seem big
and impossible are not it gives people
that type of energy Island Getaway
turned disaster it became very barbaric
American rapper Ja Rule is in the
Bahamas with his business partner Billy
McFarland is an amazing entrepreneur he
could come into anyone at pretty much
anything they just bought an island
Pablo Escobar's Island within 48 hours
they sold out when thousands arrived in
the Bahamas for the fire Festival after
paying up to fifteen hundred dollars for
a ticket and twelve thousand dollars for
a VIP experience they found a millennial
nightmare
it was basically the exact opposite of
everything we were promised prosecutors
say cost investors and customers over 26
million dollars the promoter behind the
botched fire music festival the Bahamas
has been sentenced now to six years in
prison
well Benny muthana went to prison and he
joins me now Billy mafana thank you very
much indeed for joining me
Pierce thank you for having me on your
platform huge opportunity thank you so
look I watched the Netflix documentary
and it was like watching a slow-moving
pile up on a on a freeway for you
Motorway for us where it just seemed
pretty obvious quite early on this was
not going to work and the bigger the
hole you dug the worse things got was
that how it felt for you
who appears first you are braver than me
because I've never watched documentaries
and
still can't get myself to do it but I
was just so wrong and I'd like to I
think start with telling you what I
thought that I was trying to do
so I thought that I was taking these
different people from diverse
backgrounds and bringing them together
through adventures and experiences
and when this was happening it was
almost like I found my little slice of
magic in the world as these people were
forming relationships and sharing ideas
and I really just wanted to share this
with everybody and I was just so wrong
in my approach to do that well hang on
look I'm sorry but your attempt to make
yourself out to be some magic maker uh
keen on spreading diversity it all
sounds great now but the truth is you
were trying to flee some more for cash
that's why you ended up in prison for so
long I mean it was it was a money-making
vehicle your intention was not to you
know get a lot of happy campers together
and spread love and diversity and a bit
of magic it was to empty their wallets
wasn't it
I was so wrong and
I lost everything I had in the process
and lost the support the relationships
and the trust of all of my friends and
all of my investors and all of my team
members as crazy as it sounds for me
sitting here looking back at all the
terrible decisions I made
I truly thought that I was going to pull
off this event that does not excuse the
lying to investors that I did to try to
get the capital that I thought I needed
and Pierce I was wrong I messed up I
mean you're planning another Festival
now
um called pirate I think uh which is
probably quite appropriate but why
should anybody trust you either with
money as an investment or buying a
ticket to this thing given what happened
before given you've not paid off all the
people who lost money last time
yeah that's a really good question and
in my mind there's two ways to look
there yeah in my mind there's two ways
to look at this and I think that one
option is is to essentially crawl in a
hole and die of remorse and I think
that's something a lot of people
probably want but then how does
everybody get paid and for me I need to
find pride In My Life by at least trying
to write my wrongs and make it up to
everybody that I hurt
I mean you went to prison for quite a
long time what was that experience like
yes I served around four years and I
just kept making it worse and worse upon
myself I actually ended up spending 309
days in solitary confinement so for the
first period of my life I was really
forced to sit in time out and reflect on
terrible decisions and try to understand
like what makes me tick as a human and
how I could try to do something positive
moving forward
don't know you I know what a lot of
people have said about you it's not
flattering as you know I obviously I'm
aware a lot of people lost a lot of
money and that's a serious situation it
was a crime for which you've paid your
price and it's a pretty big price to pay
would you categorize yourself as
somebody who was you know a criminal
mastermind or somebody that perhaps
others might say was just a massive
bullshitter on the make who thought he'd
get away with it and unfortunately all
his chips fled from red to Black
I think what just discussed me the most
pure especially during those 10 months
where I had nothing to look at like you
know but a concrete wall in myself is
that I was trying for six seven years to
build and launch startups and I formed
great relationships over those period
And the fact that I took advantage of
those relationships all for this purpose
of trying to be successful or big or
well known and it was just disgusting
and awful what's the one thing you've
really learned about yourself Billy
you just can't attach your personal
Pride to success or any idea of success
and it's more about the relationships
and the bond you find along the way and
I was just so insecure and thought that
my personal self-worth would be
executing a big Festival that made
everybody rich and happy and that's just
so incredibly wrong and it's how I can
find that pride and self-worth in my
day-to-day like regular life do you ever
wonder what would have happened if if it
had worked
yeah I think that's one of the biggest
misconceptions is even if the festival
succeeded I still would have gone to
jail like I lied to investors to raise
the money so even if people made money
and all the ticket holders met great
people and had the weekend of their
lives I would have been sitting in jail
for years so there's just no there's no
excuse Pierce well and to those who you
know you owe money to who are disgusted
you're having another Festival what do
you say finally to them
and once again it's like I need to find
Pride somewhere in life and my pride
hopefully in 60 years from now when I'm
on my deathbed is that I spent the
majority of my adult life trying to
write my wrongs so I'm going to go out
there and work I'm going to work
honestly I can't promise that I'm going
to succeed but I can promise I'm getting
help where I need it and trying to focus
on my skill set and whatever I do will
go towards paying everybody okay well on
one positive note you've got the right
name for the festival fire because
that's what it went all up in uh Billy
marthalam thank you for joining me I
appreciate it cheers thank you that's it
for me good night keep it unsensive
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign